بامر القانون قريه في جنوب افريقيا منعت
من استخدام الطاقه الشمسيه فما قصتها
في بلده فرانكفورتي الصغيره جنوبرج السكان
وبالاتفاق مع بعض الشركات المحليه قرروا
استثمار ما يزيد على خمسه ملايين دولار
لاقامه مزرعه للطاقه الشمسيه لتعويض
انقطاع الكهرباء الطويل وبالفعل تم
الانتهاء من تركيبها لكن هذا الوضع ازعج
السلطات هناك شركه الكهرباء المملوكه
للدوله قامت دعوه ضد الشركه المشغله
والمحكمه حكمت لصالحها ومنعت سكان القريه
من استخدام الطاقه الشمسيه بحجه الاسباب
التقنيه شركه الكهرباء قالت انه اذا سمح
لهذه القريه باستخدام الطاقه الشمسيه فان
العدوى ستنتشر بين بقيه القرى ما سيؤدي
الى انهيار الشبكه الوطنيه لانتاج
الكهرباء ما رايكم بهذا التصرف